What if I told you that the world's
first computer program that was born over
200 years ago, and what if that
programmer was a sheep lady?
Ava Lovelace was her name. Man's a genius
was nearly lost. The history daughters,
the famous romantic poet,
Lord Byron Ada,
was almost relegated as a footnote
and her father's biography in the 19th
century. At the height of
the industrial revolution,
she was pushed into the male dominion
of mathematics and science by her zealot
mother medsource by the
father of the computer.
She emerged as a woman far ahead of her
time and her ability to see what could
potentially be not as your
typical aristocratic lady.
Part of [inaudible] story holds a
shadowy secret and on her deathbed,
her last wish speaks volumes.
Today on biographics,
we explore the enchantress
of number Ada Lovelace.
Okay.
Ada Lovelace was born or Gusta eight a
Byron in London on December the 10th 1815
to the philandering romantic poet,
Lord Byron,
and strictly religious Annabella Milbanke
Eto was Lord Byron's only legitimate
child. Lord and Lady Byron were
members of high British society,
the social status,
and they shed virtually nothing in common.
Annabella was analytical and it's
conformist. While Lord Byron the cat,
little for numbers and logic, true. He
was a celebrated and the door poets,
yet it's bad behavior raised
more than a few eyebrows.
He was known to drink from a human
skull owner pat to bear and to engage in
numerous love affairs
with both men and women.
One notorious scans are involved in
the fat with his own half sister.
Let's go on to lover one set
of Lord Byron. He was mad,
bad and dangerous to know and not
surprisingly Annabella and Lord Byron's
marriage did not last beyond a year and
a contemptuous splits when Ada was only
five weeks old. Lord Byron
left the home. He wrote her.
This parting is my face like my mother's,
my Fairchild Ada sole daughter
of my house and Heart,
deeply bitter and resentful.
Lady Annabella covered his portrait with
a large curtain and four bead Ada from
ever looking at it for months after
Lord Byron left his infant daughter.
He left England for good, never to
return when Ada was eight years old,
speed died of an illness in Greece while
fighting in the war of independence.
He was 36 years old,
although I never met her father.
She remained fascinated with him and
just poetry over the course of her life.
Out of the was determined to steer
her daughter away from developing her
father's volatile at poetic
and sanity as she called us.
She truly believed Lord Byron was
mentally ill almost to the brink of
fanaticism.
Annabella saw to it that Ada received
an education rigorous and and science.
This was a rather unusual course of study
for girls in British Victorian society.
Even if Annabella herself
was gifted in math,
but I referred to her as the
princess of parallelograms.
Popular opinion of the time favored
one of adas later tutors and brilliant
mathematician or Gustus
Morgan who believed women
wearing capable of excelling
in the discipline. On the one hand,
Morgan acknowledged a disabilities. Yeah,
it's in a letter to her mother. He wrote
the very great tension of the minds,
which they require as beyond the
strength of a woman's physical power of
application.
Basically what he said was that women
weren't capable because they were not as
strong as men. Well, [inaudible],
she was going to prove that wrong.
As a young girl and into our teen years,
eight it was mostly isolators and did
not spend a great deal of time with our
mother.
Still Annabella was committed to her
daughter's education until wellbeing.
She employed some of the greatest
intellectual minds to tutor Ada,
including William King, physician,
William Friends, a social reformer,
and Mary Somerville, a Scottish
astronomer, mathematician,
and the first woman to be admitted
to the Royal Astronomical Society.
Eight or in Somerville became
close friends. In addition
to Algebra and geometry,
Ada was taught lessons in
history, literature, languages,
geography, music, sewing.
I'm shorthands.
These were all common subject areas,
but it mother pound something else.
That was far,
far more bizarre in an effort to
protect her daughter from developing her
father's impulses. Ada had to lie
still for long periods of time.
This was a lesson in self control and
it was a bright students and showed
promise from math and science. At the
age of 12 after a long tour of Europe,
she became obsessed with
birds and with flight.
She researched what she referred to you
as fly ology man's imaginatively and
methodically. You conceptualize the
flying machine that could flap it's wings.
She rides where mother,
I've got a scheme to make a thing in the
form of a horse with a steam engine in
the inside,
so contrived as to move an immense pair
of wings fixed on the outside of the
horse in such a manner to carry it up
into the air while a person sits on its
back. For her design, she considered the
type of material, paper, silk or feathers,
navigational equipment or compass and
steam the source of power in between
throwing herself into intellectual
pursuits, eight of battles, sickness.
She frequently, it complains of
headaches that obscured her vision.
In 1829 she contracted measles or common
childhood affliction in the 18 hundreds
the illness resulted in continuous bed
rest for a year and she was disabled
temporarily.
In 1831 at the age of 16 she was finally
able to walk again with the aid of
crutches by the age of 17 eight is
feeling better and in keeping with the
customs of our social class.
She was presented at court and it became
a popular bell of the season she danced
with and charms the various
attendees with her brilliant mind.
The industrial revolution was in full
force by the time Ed was a teenager.
It was a glorious time in history for
the advancement of technology and the
perfect time for the inquisitive Ada
to be coming of age. Make no mistake.
She had the makings of a phenom.
She had inherent abilities
combined with rigorous education.
She also had access to intellects,
investors and influential people empower
all because of her position in society.
All of this was the perfect storm and
meeting the famed inventive Charles
Babbage was eight as a lightening bolts
in 1833 of the 17 year old Dado was
among a select group to attend a coveted
party hosted by Babbage known by many
today has the father of the computer I
guest wrote at the time one of the three
qualifications for those who sought
to be invited where intellects,
beauty or rank Ada with those requirements
while she fit right in at the soiree,
Babbage unveiled a small
part of his latest machine,
a massive mechanical calculator
known as the difference engine.
The design for Babbage's engine was
revolutionary and it's fully constructed.
It was perform the work of an
army of men crunching numbers.
The machine would be powered by steam
and would methodically perform complex
calculations using only
edition by breaking it into
smaller and smaller pieces
known as the method of finite differences,
then is which printouts that
you values into a table.
Babbage's machine had enormous potential
in the 19th century since tables were
used in many areas, including
navigation, astronomy, and engineering.
With this powerful calculator.
Human error would be erased.
The engine was accurate within 31
decimal places so many guests that night.
Babbage's invention was a hunk of metal
and less or more than a party favor but
not to ada to Morgan's wife was there
and later wrote of the night when most of
the guests looked on with the expression
that savages show on seeing a looking
glass.
Miss Byron youngest,
she was understood it's working and
saw the great beauty of the invention.
Babbage must have been impressed with
eight as intellect and enthusiasm for the
machine from that night on. He remains
her mentor and Lifelong friends.
Babbage's difference engine would not
come to be after a disagreement with his
engineer, Joseph Clemens.
In those days by law,
the engineer owns the drawings
and after they're falling out,
he could not get them back.
Consequently,
the British government also withdrew
their funding for the projects.
This forced manage back
to his original concept,
but he came up with an even better idea
in 1834 a far more complex machine that
he called the analytical engine.
The analytical engine is considered to
be the world's very first programmable
general purpose computer.
The basic structure of the engine is
essentially the same as modern day
computers. Of course, Babbage's
machine was massive in scale.
His entry level machines would have
been 40 feet long by 15 feet high,
but he's talked about others
that were 10 times that size,
nothing like this had ever been
conceived or attempted before. In fact,
in his lifetime,
only a small trial engine was constructed.
This analytical engine, it consisted
of four components, the mill,
which calculated units,
the store where the data was held for
processing as the reader and printer,
the input and output devices.
It was truly groundbreaking and
would largely become adas legacy.
Since eight or in Babbage's first meeting,
she became his protege.
He was the teacher and she was the pupil.
After Babbage showed or the
plans for the analytical engine,
she eagerly went on a tour of cotton
mills in the north of England to see the
most technologically
advanced machine of the day.
The Jacquard loom the limb automated.
It's the weaving of patterned silk and
it was controlled by a series of punch
cards. It was fascinating and
it was also controversial.
The cotton mill with a jacquard loom
didn't need skilled workers to weave
intricate patterns while
groups such as the blood,
I'd swear protesting against
these machines on account
of replacing workers jobs.
Ada was thinking something else entirely.
She was deeply interested in the genius
behind the punch cards and wanted to
know how men were translating
the complicated patterns
into something simple.
She saw the similarities.
Do you have a loved and machine and
later wrote the analytical engine weaves
Algebraic patterns.
Just as the Chicago loom weaves flowers
and leaves for the next 10 years in
between getting married
and having three children,
eight have focused all her energy into
learning everything she could about the
analytical engine she wrote.
I think I am more determined than ever
in my future plans and I have quite made
up. My mind's that nothing must be
suffered to interfere with them.
I intend to make such
arrangements in town as well,
secure me a couple of hours daily with
very few exceptions. For my studies.
After attending one of
Babbage's rare lectures,
a military engineer in future
Italian prime minister,
Luigi man of Breyer wrote an impressive
article sketcher of the analytical
engine invented by Charles Babbage Squire.
The paper was extremely detailed and
mathematical and there was also written in
French.
Ada decided to translate the paper and
since she knew the engines so well she
could add her own thoughts
to us any years later.
Babbage claim to have told
data to translate it and
write her own accounts and
she responded by saying she
hadn't thought of it either way,
she went about the task like a devil
possessed and when she was finished her
notes with three times as long as the
original paper eight or published or
completed article in scientific memoirs
and English Scientific Journal published
by Richard Taylor in 1843 a. Dot.
Only used her initials on the paper.
Aal Standing for Augusta,
Ada Lovelace.
The parts of the paper that gives wait
ages creditors first computer programmer
comes in section g and it's eight a
wrote of how the engine could be programs
with a code to calculate
Bernoulli numbers.
This was an algorithm to be carried out
by a machine and thus the first computer
program along with numbers eight Ada
describes how codes could be created for
the device so it could
handle letters and symbols.
She also theorized a method for the engine
to repeat a series of instructions or
looping a process.
Computer programs still used today.
Hey are also offered other other concepts
in her paper such as her thoughts on
artificial intelligence.
She wrote,
the analytical engine has no pretentions
want to have to originate anything.
It can do whatever.
We know how to order it to perform.
It can follow analysis but it has no
power of anticipating any analytical
relations or truths.
Her notes worked significance and that
they captured aiders vision for the
analytical engine and this is where she
exceeds her mentor and her understanding
of its full potential.
Babbage's historian wrote eight or saw
something that Babbage in some sense fail
to see in Babbage's weld his engines.
We're bound by number.
What lovely saw was that number could
represent entities other than quantity.
Looking back from the present
high ground of modern computing.
If we are looking and sifting
history for that transition,
then that transition was
made explicitly by Ada.
In that 1843 paper.
Babbage was impressed with Ada and wrote,
the more I read your notes,
the more surprised I am Andrew guys
and not having earlier explored.
So richer vein of the noblest metal.
The next obvious step for the analytical
engine would have been Babbage's and
adas crowning moments,
but it would not come to pass.
Babbage was known to be a difficult
man and he argued with politicians,
so for his machines, the relationship
with parliaments was particularly salad.
After Babbage fail to deliver his
government funded difference engine,
the loss of money in those days was the
equivalent to two Royal Navy warships.
Ada had a plan to promote the engine,
but it was a sensitive subjects.
One she breached in a letter dated August
the 14th 1843 she asked about Ej if
she could take over him for promoting
the analytical engine while he stepped
aside and focus only on building it.
She ended up with you will
won them over this last query,
but I strongly advise you not to
reject us. Vantage though he said no,
refusing all of her conditions that
interest would not give up control and he
likely saw her asking
as an audacious move.
Okay.
Depending on the lens you use to evaluate
data, she can be hailed as a genius,
say Victorian High Society Lady,
a mother and wife, a Gambler,
adulterous or drug addicts and truth.
She may have been all of those things.
She was like most of us complex and
contradictory as one would expect a to
married and had children.
She went William King,
not William King who was a tutor in 1835
at the age of 19 he was 30 king seem to
be a precise, conscientious and
decent man if somewhat stiff.
Three years after they tied the knots,
king became the Earl of Lovelace.
Ada took the title account
tests of Lovelace. They had
three children together.
Byron born may of 1836 and Isabella
called Annabella born in September of 1837
and Ralph Gordon born in July of 1839
four at a time between 1835 and 1839 eight
or focused most of our energy
running the large households.
She found herself time for horse riding,
learning the harp and studying mathematics
after their third child was born,
eight or 10 tev retention back to
maths and the sciences and was Tuesday.
It's by Augustus to Morgan and her
husband. King were supportive socially.
The couple had many prominent friends
and acquaintances including the writer
Charles Dickens.
In addition to you headaches and since
the measles suffered in childhood,
Ada had recurrent health
problems as an adult.
After about of color in 1837 she had
problems with asthma and her digestive
system. She was prescribed a powerfully
addictive painkiller and opiates,
which was to be taken with wine.
The drug altered her personality and she
reported hallucinations and mood swings.
In 1841 ada and Maduro relieve the
daughter of Lord Byron's half sister or
Gustus Lee were told why Adas mother,
that Lord Byron was also Madora his father
in February eight a road to another.
I am not in the least astonished.
In fact,
you merely confirm what I have for years
and years, felt scarcely a doubt about,
but should have considered it in proper
in me to hinted to you that I in any way
suspect it. She did not blame the
incestuous relationship on her father,
but instead blamed or Gusta Lee.
I fear she is more inherently wicked
than he ever was in the 1840 [inaudible]
has self flirted with scandals first
with relaxed relationships with men who
went. Also husbands, which led to rumors.
She was having affairs and then an
old family vice surfaced. Haters.
Life took a shadowy turn in 1851
when she began gambling on horses.
Perhaps she was trying in vain to raise
funds for her beloved analytical engine,
but no one really knows. Hey
Deb, she did not act alone.
She was part of a gambling
ring and in the spring season,
hot bats went horribly wrong.
It has been said,
I ate a may have devised
a mathematical scheme.
Do you predict the winning horses? If
so, though it didn't work in a fails,
battered the EPSOM Debbie Ada ended up
owing the equivalent of roughly half a
million pounds to get out of her dad.
She pawned off some of the family jewels
in 1852 80 became gravely ill man.
She took to her bed.
She died painfully and slowly.
A future in cancer on November the 27th
1852 at the age of 36 the exact age her
father had been a few
months before she died.
She made an unknown confession to our
husbands that made him leave her bad side,
her final wish. Where's an act
of defiance against her mother.
Ada wants to be buried next to the
man who loomed large in her life,
but she never knew her father age.
His body was taken miles away from our
home to the buyer and family volts inside
the Church and sit and Mary Magdalene and
the small English town of [inaudible].
Yeah,
that's brain of mine is something
more than merely mortal.
As time will show eight his
contributions were buried for 100 years,
discovered by a scientist,
Alan Turing in the 1940s during the second
world war during with something of a
kindred spirit who was also
interested in the same things.
She was machines that
could act upon instruction.
His work ultimately led to the effort
to build a machine with the code name,
the bomb that deciphered
encrypted messages sent by hit.
This armed forces tierings work had begun
before reading eight his notes on the
analytical engine, yet he was
greatly influenced by them.
She, along with Babbage,
essentially paved the way for tiering
who is considered today as the father of
theoretical computer science and
artificial intelligence. Consequently,
as notes surfaced for the weld and BV
Bowden's Book Faster Than Thought a
symposium on digital computing machines
from 1953 then during the 1970s in the u
s department of Defense develops a high
order computer programming language to
supersede the hundreds of different
ones then in use by the military.
This programming language was named Ada.
They is still used around the world today
and the operation of real time systems
in the aviation health care,
transportation,
financial infrastructure and space
industries in the present day in
international celebration takes place
on the second Tuesday of October.
That would be Ada Lovelace day founded
in 2009 by sue Sharmane Anderson.
It's aim is to recognize the achievements
of women in science, technology,
engineering and maths.
It also has the goal of increasing the
profile of women in these areas and in
doing so,
creating new role models who will
encourage more girls into these sectors.
Ada is everywhere in our
modern digital wells,
immortalized on the internet forever
in news articles, blog posts, memes,
quotable quotes.
There's even some controversy of whether
or not she deserves the claim of first
computer programmer,
but there is no denying her
vision surpassed any of her
contemporaries including
Babbage in all his 11 volumes of
published writings he never wrote of the
aspirations for computing like Ada has,
those who have learned to walk on the
threshold of unknown worlds by means of
what's are commonly termed par excellence.
The exact sciences may then with
the fairways, wings of imagination,
hope to saw further into the
unexplored mist which we live.
So I really hope you enjoyed that
episode of biographics. If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put our brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube. If you actually want to
get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time, every Monday
and Thursday when we put out a new video.
Also, if you want to watch
something else right now,
stuff from the archive over
there on the right and as always,
thank you for watching.